before men with alleged ties to Isis are
in custody in Morocco after the killing
of two European tourists the two female
victims were University students from
Scandinavia their bodies with stab
wounds were discovered Monday in the
mountains south of Marrakesh Holly
Williams is following the investigation
from Istanbul Turkey Holly good morning
good morning the two women were on a
hiking trip camping in Morocco's Atlas
Mountains when they were killed they've
been identified as Louisa vest Roger yes
person from Denmark and Myra Norland
from Norway their bodies were apparently
discovered by two French hikers Moroccan
authorities have arrested four suspects
in the city of Marrakech they were
reportedly found in possession of knives
and Morocco's general prosecutor has
confirmed that a video in which those
suspects swear allegiance to Isis and
threatened to carry out attacks is
authentic now Morocco has actually
experienced very few terror attacks in
recent years but many of its citizens
have joined terrorist groups elsewhere
including Isis there are now fears that
these murders could damage Morocco's
crucial tourism industry which accounts
for an estimated 10% of the country's
income the Moroccan government has
condemned these killings as a quote
criminal terrorist act and a stab in the
back of Morocco biana devastating news
Holly Williams in Istanbul thank you